geologically yes in the Bible when the
prophet Nathan goes to hold David who is
the king of the King accountable and he
tells him a story and he kisses him he
tells me sir oh my god where's this
guy's doing he says you were the man
you're the one the the job of the
Prophet is different from the job of
Pharaoh Jeremiah Wright is Moses is a
prophet is Jeremiah Isaiah Barack Obama
is Pharaoh that's not a diss on him
that's his job his job is to govern the
country he cannot be a prophet so people
who were looking for Barack Obama to be
a prophet were misled it's what
philosophers call a category mistake
that ain't his job his job is to do what
he's doing and and and Jeremiah Wright
said that he said his job is to do one
thing my job is to do another the
problem is April that they they they
drove a wedge between them in a way that
was unnecessary because many black
ministers have pastored many black
political figures in this country
without having that wedge driven between
them but the stakes were never this high
and in Barack Obama and Jeremiah Wright
met at a fork that that that divided
them forever unfortunately as Robert
Frost said two roads diverged in the
yellow wood and I I took the one less
traveled by that there was never a road
that the one less traveled by was the
presidential road we'd gone down the
prophetic Road we got a million prophets
we we ain't got but one potential
president and black people like Liz look
I know your prophet you know pastor and
mama are real close together mama then
pastor don't we talk about my pastor and
and Obama got away with it because black
people read his quest for the presidency
as a divinely ordained one so he usurped
the prophetic prerogative of Jeremiah
right and then it was cast upon him so
Jeremiah Wright ironically enough
although all of his life working for the
end result of black political power was
himself disempowered at the very moment
when he should have been riding gunshot
with the so to speak Barack Obama and
Barack Obama the Pharoah figure now
assumed prophetic power it was a
brilliant and ingenious move shrewd on
many ways
but also unfortunate because Barack
Obama would not be who he is without
Jeremiah Wright being who he is in the
time that we have remaining the black
presidency Barack Obama and the politics
of race in America eerily familiar to
another book title the presidency in
black and white three presidents race
America but thank you so much for being
controversial always sparking
conversation and making us think that's
who you are and in what is the takeaway
from this book for for the American
public in the time but the few remaining
moments we have left people can feel my
love for this man because I do love him
as a human being I see his greatness
I see his remarkable imprint upon this
culture but I also have an obligation to
lovingly criticize him and to engage him
in a conversation doesn't mean I'm right
because I will be in turn criticize
myself that's good that's a give and
take that's the back and forth of what
it means to engage in conversation I'm a
teacher I'm a professor that's what we
do that's my job but in the ultimate end
of the road so to speak I want people to
see that I gave him a fair shake I tried
to understand what he was working
against I tried to understand what his
goals and objectives were and the things
he did that were great in the things he
did were not so great and in aggregate
and in an inhuman civ impact this book
is a measure of one of the most
extraordinary figures that has ever
darkened the halls of American politics
author Michael Eric Dyson the black
presidency Barack Obama had the politics
of race in America thank you Michael
thank you so much
when I tuned into it on the weekend
usually it's authors sharing up their
new releases watching the nonfiction
authors on book TV is the best
television for serious readers on c-span
they can have a longer conversation and
delve into their subject book TV
weekends they bring you author after
author after author that spotlight the
work of fascinating people
I love book TV and I'm a c-span fans
crystal Wright is back at our desk she's
editor and publisher of conservative
black chick calm also out with the new
book on job how Democrats gave us crime
sanctuary cities abortion profiteering
and racial division crystal right a lot
to get into in that title of your book
but I want to begin with this quote from
your book
it reads real racism still exists in
modern America and it hurts real people
but when hustlers like Al Sharpton and
other liberals are quick to label every
incident in America racist from voter ID
laws to the shooting of black teens it
diminishes the rightful attention that
true racism should receive so what is
true racism and why are some of the
issues that you bring up in in that
example not true racism well I actually
devote a chapter in the book con job to
true racism it's in the appendix and
it's my family's personal story of being
discriminated against when I was a
little girl and they applied to a
country club and we're told that they
didn't want my parents to be members
because they were blacks and that case
actually went all the way up to the US
Court of Appeals at the time in 1980-81
when it went to the appeals court the US
Justice Department filed an amicus brief
because it said that in you know that 13
years after the Civil Rights Act has had
passed this is not what America was
about so that to me is true racism and
discrimination I would say you know when
someone is denied access to something
that is true racist discrimination when
people are called the n-word outright by
white supremacists that is
discrimination
kleavon Bundy the
rancher the incendiaries things he said
about black people that's racism
what's happened now and I write about
this in con job is you have this
industry where people like Al Sharpton
and Cornel West are getting rich off of
calling everything racism jumping into
racial division incidents in the United
States and profiting on it Jesse Jackson
is another one that to me is not being a
champion for ending discrimination
that's a champion for self in making
money and you say it's it's something
that the Democratic Party is is trading
off of but yes to profit in votes and
money it is trading off of that because
right now you see the narrative playing
out on the Democrat side we have Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders which are the
Democrat frontrunner the only ones vying
for the Democrat nomination in this
presidential election and they're
pandering to black lives matters we saw
last year when Bernie Sanders was at an
event
he didn't give what black people felt
was appropriate lip service to black
lives matters and he was heckled off the
stage what is that I mean I'm a black
person I find that offensive I want to
hear from candidates policies to make
all lives better so right now you have
there's a race going on on the Democrat
side with the candidates to get
so-called black endorsements there it's
fast and furious they're meeting with Al
Sharpton I don't know about you Jon but
I'm a black woman I speak for myself you
as a white man don't have white people
telling you how to vote where is Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders why aren't
they getting the endorsement of
so-called white America and white
spokespeople I find it offensive it's
there's nothing real in it they should
be talking about their agenda for black
America and they have none we know that
Hillary Clinton in 1994 supported her
husband's crime bill which locked up and
incarcerated more black men than any
president in US history
he created the disparagement between
sentencing of crack and crack cocaine
and cocaine that led to the mass
incarceration of black Americans I would
argue that neither candidate has done
anything in their decades of service to
improve the lives of black Americans in
the 2014 election 89 percent of black
Americans
for Democrats and you argue in your book
that they're voting against their their
own interests when when they do that how
do you try to change that mindset to
change those numbers 89 percent well
it's not just yeah it's 89 percent of
the country and it's also overwhelmingly
you have over 90 percent of black
Americans the last two election cycles
voting for the first black president
United States of America in 2008 and
2012 and I talked about this in con job
the subtitle of the book is how
Democrats gave us crime sanctuary cities
abortion profits are in a racial
division and the reason why I wrote the
book is to really expose to America the
lies that I believe the Democrat Party
is based on I have 50 pages of mostly
government data to prove every point I
talk about abortion is not a friend of
women's health because according to
Planned Parenthood 3 out of 10 women by
the time they turn age 45 will have had
an abortion you tell me about how that's
promoting women's health you know we
should be talking about accidents we
should be talking about the you know if
a woman comes into an abortion clinic
she should be getting counseling on you
can have your baby you can put your baby
up for adoption but none of that is
happening and Planned Parenthood is
getting 40% government funding to fund
their 1.3 billion dollars I think I
talked about in the book that they made
2013 or 2014 and with black Americans -
what I also talked about is oftentimes
you see Democrats pitting one
constituent against another they
actually cannibalize constituents
because there's no party that can be all
things to all people that's that's the
failure of identity politics so on the
one hand you have Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders and Barack Obama talking
about illegal immigration which is
actually the enemy of black employment
in this country so there's you know I
could probably go on and on but I'll let
you I'll stop lots of gets you there
because we want to bring in our colors
phones are open Democrats it's two to
seven four eight eight thousand
Republicans 202 seven four eight eight
thousand and one independence 202 seven
four eight eight thousand two let's get
to a few calls
James Hollywood Florida line for
Democrats you're up first with crystal
right
jain's go ahead James you got to stick
by your phone we'll go to Jos came from
Kissimmee Florida lying for Republicans
Josh you're on the Washington journal
good morning I would like to ask your
guest exactly how does he feel about the
narrative that all Republicans are
racist in the fact that my daughter and
I my daughter who's racially mixed we
went to the Trump rally in Orlando last
weekend and the crowd to see Trump was
racially mixed there was no nobody was
saying racial epitaphs and I like that
and how can we get around a media's
false narrative that's a great question
and that's why well that's why I wrote
con job but that's also why I started my
blog conservative black chick to break
through the stereotype that somehow
because black people were born with a
certain skin color we are relegated to
the Democrat box and if you go back in
history you know way before 1964 when
the Democrat Party one started owning
the black vote lock stock and barrel
because lyndon b johnson actually signed
the Civil Rights Act into law and he he
marshaled it through really for
political expediency before that you had
Republicans actually champion all all
the things that that now the Democrat
Party is giving lip service to and says
that it's the champions up but I think
more importantly it's people like you
and me
speaking out and saying you just told me
you were at the Trump rally you didn't
have people calling each other
incendiary names and I do not believe
that that Donald Trump is a racist I do
I would have liked him to repudiate much
stronger when he came out against the
David Duke support and white supremacist
support he has since done that saying
that he doesn't want that kind of
support he can't control who votes for
him but he needs to talk in the vein of
Ronald Reagan and say hey if I'm elected
president I'm gonna bring all people
together and I'm gonna burp you d8 that
kind of a you know trash talk and racist
talk are you voting for Donald Trump the
cycle
I have not endorsed a candidate or
decided you know who I'm going to
support in the DC
crime area I will vote in the DC primary
as a Republican that there are those of
us who exist we're a little over 30,000
I like what Donald Trump's candidacy is
doing to the political establishment
called the Republican Party because they
are toned death death to inclusion and
that's why we're in the state we are and
I predict that that the party will be
born in new even if Trump doesn't
prevail and being the nominee or or
elected I was going to note in your
column about Donald Trump and this issue
of the white supremacist and his
comments about that you note some
criticism for the Republican
establishment that the establishment has
done nothing to grow the party beyond
its college-educated white base end
quote
over the past four years yeah it hasn't
i I remember vividly when MIT Romney
became our nominee and I was a Newt
Gingrich supporter and delegate here in
DC I tried at every turn to volunteer
for mr. Romney's campaign never got
responses I was on television supporting
him supporting his wife Ann Romney and
he ran one of the whitest campaigns in
recent memory and and and and and what
that mean well that means that while
Barack Obama was using even though I
don't believe in Barack Obama's policies
perception becomes reality mr. President
Obama had people of color he enlisted
actresses in Hollywood to go out there
and and help him as surrogates with his
campaign he you didn't have his
surrogates looking like the who's who of
white America very opposite was true of
mr. Romney not just in in the people
that he was using to talk on his behalf
but his campaign largely white males he
had a bunch of coalition's you know I've
got the african-american coalition the
Asian coalition but that's all they
weren't in name only and that was
reflected in the votes that Mitt Romney
won Mitt Romney won 60% of the white
vote that was more than any president
and one in 1988 and we see the path Ford
is not just the white vote you know our
nominee today in 2016 is going to have
to peel off minorities women
independence so you know we're in so I
thought it was really disingenuous and
really an affront for Mitt Romney to get
there and start blasting Donald Trump
when he lost an election in 2012 that
many people say that he should have won
so you know he yeah my party has it has
problems on inclusion back to the phones
line for Democrats Pookie is waiting
line from Waldorf Maryland
go ahead Pookie hi yes good morning
c-span and good morning to your guests I
have a feeling that herself and I would
probably not agree on many things but
after hearing her I think I might change
my opinion so the first is I I do
sincerely disagree with you respectfully
but with your definition of true racism
versus I suppose you you you categorize
it into not racism or no racism I think
your definition should be broadened to
include both covert versus overt racism
I think that's really the definitions
that you probably should be seeking too
but my other statement is that I agree
with you in some aspects and that the
the Democratic Party probably should not
have a lock on the black vote I I think
that that's not very it's it's not very
informed of voters to simply vote your
karti I myself would I suppose I
identify as a Democrat because I've only
voted democratically in every election
however I you know as I get older as I
become more informed and and they become
I suppose more active in the political
process I think I have changed my
understanding of who I should vote for
and maybe I'm more of an independent
than a Democrat but I yeah I'm gonna
like crystal right jump it thanks Pookie
and you make some great ABS
patience and you know I think racism if
I had more time I don't want to dominate
the short time I have we're talking
about the different types of racism I
experienced racism from professors when
I was in college in high school so there
are you know we probably don't we don't
have enough time to go into all that but
I think about her preferred definition
let's talk about covert and overt racism
well look I think that I believe more
there's overt racism that we see that we
hear right and I gave some examples
there is covert racism in hiring plaqued
practices now still with Fortune 500
companies you have racism do do taxi cab
drivers in major cities still look at
black men in in a suit and tie and still
won't pick them up certainly they do but
that goes to my point if every but if
all white people are racist like Al
Sharpton wants to label people what's
happening now is you have huge massive a
chasm of racial division in this country
because people like Al Sharpton al
Sharpton if he was really interested in
making the races to come together he
wouldn't jump into every scenario like
you know Baltimore Michael Brown Trayvon
Martin he would actually take a step
back but he goes down there he flaps his
loud mouth and he creates tension
tension that doesn't produce anything
but friction and violence and I think
that back to what else Pookie said I
also wrote the book con job because I am
NOT trying to convince all black people
that they have to vote Democrat I'm
saying that she pointed out that black
people have have no political influence
we gave that up over the last 50 plus
years that we have voted single handedly
for one political party no other race
does that and just because you have a D
or an or next year name I have an R next
to my name does that mean that I'm
always going to wrote Republican know
every every election cycle people
politicians have to earn my vote and I
think black people need to hold the
politicians accountable specifically the
Democrat Party who has not delivered on
the promises to blacks over the last 50
plus years right now you have two
candidates on the Democrat side
promising that black lives matter
and it's the same lip service we've
heard the last four years the last eight
years before that and I would argue
since nineteen you know over half a
century
black mines have not mattered to
Democrats black lives black educate you
know black education has gotten worse
black prosperity and wealth has gone
down everything's gone down the toilet
when you look at black lives one more
passage from the book you write the
black lives matter campaign has become
nothing more than an excuse for young
black men to get confrontational with
police particularly white officers
across the country to jeopardize their
own lives and to provide the Democrats
and their race Charlotte's and allies
with another incident they will leverage
into more rioting looting and votes for
candidates with addy after their name
the book is con job how Democrats gave
us crime sanctuary cities abortion
profiteering and race racial division
crystal Wright wrote the book is our
guest for about the next twenty five
minutes Nevins been waiting in signal
Mountain Tennessee line for independence
and having good morning hey good morning
thank you for taking my call and just as
fast comment two quick comments I don't
think really it's just as simple as
racism and racial it's more economic and
just by you know your personal history
obviously you're not high socio-economic
group it's it's that's why the Democrats
appeal it's it's it's a working-class
situation and it's not really racism
it's just my comment thank you well I'm
gonna disagree with you on that because
Democrats when it comes to black
Americans there's the number one thing
that's causing most of the crime and
lack of education that my race is
experiencing yet they continue to vote
for the same party to continue to give
them the same results seventy two
percent of all black babies are born out
of wedlock that means they're more black
babies are born into homes without a mom
and a dad and whether you look at
Brookings Institute or heritage which
are polar opposites one is on the right
one is on the Left all the data shows
that when a child is born into that kind
of situation their chances of falling
into poverty not graduating from high
school and fall into crime or
exponential it's over like seventy
percent so if
Democrats were really interesting I
talked about this in the book con job in
solving this problem they would look at
how how do we stop blacks from having
the and it's not just one generation
it's its its many generations and it
started happening in the early 60s when
Daniel Patrick Moynihan who was a
Democrat senator and he worked for
President Johnson he wrote the the
Moynihan report the Negro family a case
for national action is the formal term
of it and he wrote to President Johnson
when he was then assistant secretary of
labor he said whoa Johnson I'm concerned
here Huston alert alert you've got
twenty three percent of black babies
being born into homes without fathers
and I'm seeing a rising increase of
black women depending on welfare so fat
and the men going into jail so
fast-forward to today the problem has
only gotten more cute and President
Obama's solution was my brothers keepers
program it was more coddling of young
black men for the this was basically a
nanny program I write about it in con
job it was a federal government program
that actually was going to teach black
men how to be men now that's the
responsibility of the parents we have to
stop we need to be teaching abstinence
programs and personal responsibility so
I disagree with a caller that it's about
socio economics yeah it's it's about
it's about more than that you have more
black Americans that are not taking
responsibility for their lives so their
plight you know is never going to change
and they keep voting for a party that
continues to keep them in the state of
victimization let's go to our line for
Republicans where Ola is waiting in
Bowie Maryland hola good morning good
morning how are you doing go ahead what
a great job of presenting the issues
every time I present the issues the way
that you presented I get called every
name in the book you know and I'm not
going to repeat and I just have I'll
tell people I present the issue the
winner is I deal in dinner
in fact that's opposition and innuendo I
cannot do it
now the one thing I will say is this is
that on a per capita basis I think most
of the discrimination that we face right
now is social economics
it's just more is this more heightened
on a per capita basis but everything you
say
I completely agree with now the issue
that I have is this is that how do we
teach and because I do volunteer and I
teach young men twice a week how do we
now teach the younger generation not to
fall into the trap of the Democrats like
the Holy Grill that saves everyone
because I do it twice a week we young
adult age ranges from eighteen to thirty
and most of them say to me most of them
I'm talking about a group of thirty guys
most of them say to me I don't care
about reason I know it is there hey I
worry about what it is that I need to do
personally you achieve everything that
God wants me to achieve and be a hundred
percent of the person that I can be with
my potential and ability that's really
the key not that cuddly not my brother's
keeper it's more about personal
responsibility so good job keep doing
what you're doing and hopefully one day
I'll run into you and I within the DC
circle okay well the caller raises
important issue solutions right I talked
about the negatives but there are
solutions and I think the solution is
talking more about what Paul where
Speaker Paul Ryan is doing which is how
do we Speaker Paul Ryan is bringing
forward policies on how to prevent
poverty through work and personal
responsibility and empowerment and a lot
of this goes back to his when he worked
for Jack Kim and we talked about Jack
Kemp had these ideas of enterprise zones
you know he said that if businesses want
to go into like you know places like
Baltimore where you have torn down
buildings and there's no opportunity for
young black people who are trying to
break that generational cycle then Jack
Kemp said we're gonna give tax credits
to these businesses to set up shop
in Baltimore and torn down you know
predominantly black cities where there's
no economic opportunity but I think it's
also about mentoring and talking to
young people and and really explaining
that you know when you have a job you're
able to buy things when you're when you
finish high school and get a high school
education you're able to empower
yourself to actually get that job
then maybe go to college I don't think
it should be College College colleges
for everybody getting in today we need
to get back to vocational training and
it's also telling young people what
happens when you have a baby when you're
not ready for a baby when you have a
baby out of wedlock and talking
abstinent and in the book I talk about
the best friends foundation program
which in Lane Bennett started and she
also this is a program that was teaching
young girls to graduate from high school
not engage in premarital sex until they
finished high school focus on going to
college not doing drugs and alcohol it
was a curriculum program taught in about
14 public schools and including the
District of Columbia so she had that
program for almost 20 years she started
the best men's program about ten years
ago and the current President Barack
Obama once he got elected in 2009 he
defunded all federal government money
for abstinence training programs and
I'll just leave the caller with this
other example my mom is a tutor through
her church and she goes in and tutors
elementary kids you know in the school
that the church adopts and she told me
that a couple years ago she was tutoring
a young grade schooler and this black
child did not know what a husband was
the term was foreign to her it was
Valentine's holiday was coming up and my
mother was explained to the little girl
that she was gonna send Valentine's
cards to her kids and give one to her
husband and the little girl said what's
a husband to my mom explained to her
what a husband was and she she responded
back to my mother husband boyfriend
they're all the same and this is the
narrative we need to break they're not
all the same and if anything black
people the black race needs husbands
they need fathers Leesburg Virginia's
next line for Democrats Karen is up
Karen good morning good morning um I
need to say this I'm not being
disrespectful but crystal you were
talking about a to size amount you know
this is one of the problems or what I
see is that swapping african-american
people don't look at all white people as
they're racist I look
will you act not because of your skin
color but I asked I look at you and how
you treat others you cannot admit that
racism still exists whether it is over
however way you want to put it and then
turn around and I understand or
empathize that people like our shop is
out here to bring that to attention
because the truth of the matter is a lot
of white people a lot of white friends
but it do not see racism because they
never experience it but that doesn't
mean it doesn't exist so I don't blame
whether is Al Sharpton you everybody
else is going to bring it to the
attention of the national media or when
it's due but I do want to jump on this
issue real quick about unwed mothers
there are you're right there the
American community that do not have
fathers but guess what they're the same
women asylum is for the lives outside of
Kentucky too so let's not try to
sugarcoat an act like this is just an
African American thing Planned
Parenthood serves every community across
America including the inner city so when
we watch when you start to have
discussions like this on a public forum
you need to put it out there and make
your rachel carson with your next book
not about what the Democrats in that
door for the african-american community
community and it's what the Republicans
are not do it for the african-american
community and within a door for the
Latino community and for all minorities
because if you don't want to use this as
a platform then do it 100% no sugar call
it into the black community all right
got your point what I give crystal right
a chance to respond yeah well I think
Karen has a little chip on her shoulder
and she doesn't like the fact that I am
producing facts
black Americans represent 13% of the
population
72% of their babies are born out of
wedlock black men are killing each other
at a rate and being killed by each other
much higher than any other race
according to the Justice Department
Karen blacks are six times blacks or six
times as likely to commit homicides and
seven times as likely to be homicide
victims the number one cause of death of
young black men ages 15 to 34 is
homicide okay ninety-three percent of
those deaths are due to homicide so we
have a pathology black Americans that is
just
Porcia 'not to white Americans and when
you look at welfare per capita more
blacks or blorp more black women or
living in public housing because they're
having babies out of wedlock and in the
book on job Karen not my fax the
Washington Post fax there was an article
in 2010 and Kolbert King and many others
seized on this we're at the it was 2010
or 2011 the District of Columbia wanted
to reduce the period that women could be
on welfare assistance so the post
article referenced about four or five
black women they didn't just have one
baby out of wedlock they had two three
four and and I think one woman even had
five by different men and at the time
mayor berry the black mayor of DC said
that he felt that this was a problem
this is a black mayor talking about a
black problem and you know what one of
the young women said when she was told
that she was going to possibly lose some
of her assistants who's gonna pay for my
pampers and you talk about what
Republicans are doing Republicans like
Paul Ryan want to in this cycle and
whenever they want to reform welfare
their blasted education Republicans lead
on school choice programs which Barack
Obama defunds every chance he got in
every budget that he submitted to
Congress school choice charter schools
vouchers have been under assault by
Democrats in favor of the teachers union
these help minorities blacks Hispanics
let's go to our line for Republicans
Richards been waiting in Fort Myers
Beach Florida Richard you're on with
crystal right Richard you there Richard
I've got a stake higher phone Richard go
to call Virginia Beach Virginia line for
independence Paul go ahead yes thank you
for taking my call um I have to quick
John take her Thomas off the air
my first one is when I turned on I kept
hearing miss Wright making all the
running down this list of reasons why
African Americans should not vote the
Democrat she mentions talked about
President Obama's program
all these other things why we should not
vote for Democrat but my problem if that
is your not this thing in any reasons
why we should vote for the Republic I
haven't heard one thing but my second
quick point is this um even though and I
kind of agree with you that the
Democrats have not been perfect have not
done everything correctly for the
African American community are you
saying that actually actually because of
that going to the voting booth in
November and vote for a party whose
front runner has not only been endorsed
by the x0 of the KKK but also the
current leader of the KKK you can look
that up and a white separatist named
Uriah Taylor and during the debate your
own publican candidate are on stage
telling penis jokes so do you really
think that because the Republican Party
I really do it crack and I've been
perfect on an American issue that I had
an african-american male she boot in
November any vote for the clown show you
have won a Republican Party are you got
your point okay thank you
I think it's really sad that you're
voting for the clown show called the
Democrats and I think it's sad then all
your your diatribe to me about the
Democrat Party you never told me once
why you're voting for them but you laugh
you laugh it oh why should I vote
Republican well frankly you should give
the Republican Party a try because the
Democrats have kept blacks poor dumber
and more criminalized and I can
everything I have said is true we are
not we've had a over a half a century of
affirmative action programs and we are
not we are still not graduating at the
rate of white Americans with all this
affirmative action all these
scholarships that are thrown at black
Americans we're not graduating at
college or high school at the same rate
of white when you talk about wealth as
of 2013 the average black family and
this is again having voted over a half a
century for Democrats and
twice for the first black president
United States black Americans have about
$19,000 in wealth compared to one
hundred and thirty thousand dollars for
the average white family crime I've
already been through that and you also I
think it's interesting you laugh at the
notion of voting for a Republican when
Republicans you look at the Republican
agenda which is an agenda of
personal responsibility and empowerment
education is the great equalizer and you
cannot there's no denying and I talked
about this when I talked about this the
charter school movement the school
voucher program Democrats want to
protect the teachers union so the
teachers union is something that that
they will always stand by they they any
chance they get they try to destroy the
charter school movement the school
choice movement President Barack Obama
sued his Justice Department sued
Louisiana's school choice program under
governor bobby jindal because you know
why Eric Holder said he couldn't have
the black kids leaving the schools
because it would make the schools the
failing schools wouldn't have enough
diversity they'd be too white I mean
what kind of nonsense is that
and I would argue with you I've talked
roundly about Donald Trump's comments
with respect to the white supremacist
and David dukes supporting him I do not
believe that Donald Trump is a racist he
needs to come out strong and hard if he
on the one hand talks about earning the
black vote which he says that you know
he can do and he can beat Hillary he
can't talk out of both sides of his
mouth but Donald Trump is the only
candidate even on when you compare him
to Hillary and Bernie Sanders on the
Democrat side Donald Trump's immigration
plan actually talks about how he's going
to ease black unemployment besides
saying that black votes matter to
Hillary and Bernie and Hillary Clinton
talking in a black dialect I just told
you how in 1994 you know she called when
when she supported Bill Clinton's crime
bill she called young black men who were
criminals super predators so here's my
thing if you're happy with the return on
your investment you're getting from
Democrats you keep laughing all
way all the way to the ballot box line
for Republicans Anne's waiting in Ormond
Beach Florida and good morning you're on
with Chris all right
I could so hire new admire you so much
and the gentleman that God about four
phone calls ago he was right on
everything you are doing so good I
really do admire you you have told the
truth on lots of things I'm a 73 year
old lady and I have been through a lot
of things I've never been a racist I
never will be all white people are not
racist and I so much appreciate your
getting that point across like you have
and thank you so much for taking my call
bye-bye
thanks Ann and and brings up a good
point now we live in such a polarized
environment and again I'm going to go
back to Al Sharpton and some of these
so-called black spokespeople because you
know I didn't know that black people
have to have other people speak on our
behalf but the Al Sharpton's have really
painted a picture under the first black
president and look I'm not saying that
are there people in this country who
can't who disdain the fact that we have
a black president sure are they racist
absolutely and I have never said
anything but and I condemn that when
people used to send around you know
pictures of gorillas and monkeys and
comparing them to the President and the
First Lady Michelle Obama that is
abhorrent you will always have sick
minded racist like that but now if
people critici-- if you're a white
person and you criticize this black
president even if you say you you start
to open your mouth oh you're racist you
just don't like him because he's he's a
black president and that is just
fundamentally not true many people feel
as though our President President Barack
Obama is taken the country in a wrong
direction and when white somehow I can
say
because I'm black so so I'm giving
license to criticize the black president
but all the other presidents before
Barack Obama were roundly criticized by
people of all races and black people the
very black people hurt telling white
people that they owe you you can't you
know it's off-limits to criticize the
black president they were the same
people criticizing president george w
bush because he was white calling him
all sorts of names and white presidents
who were republican before them so I
appreciate the call and and I would like
it for all of us regardless of our skin
color to feel as though we can weigh in
on race issues I find it really
offensive that usually when a program is
having a discussion on race I find that
I'm called in there might be a token
white person but primarily these panels
are made up of people of color and
that's you're never gonna get a true
discussion that way about five minutes
left with crystal right and lots of
calls for you Scott is on our line for
independence Silver Spring Maryland
Scott good morning crystal I'm a friend
of crystals from years back hi crystal
hey Scott I'm calling because I wanted
there's a lot of venom and these are
complicated subject matters I'm an
independent but I wanted to I hear a lot
of venom directed towards crystal and I
know crystal for a long time
and we used to actually argue and own
issues I'm a Caucasian male and she
would defend I would argue that there's
been a lot of progress for the
african-american did she would say no
there's not been enough I'm not even
sure what political affiliation she was
at that at that time I'm thinking of it
but she was there was a heartfelt thing
she was trying to figure out the truth
and so when I hear a lot of venom the
sort of torture I'm not saying I always
agree with her or I disagree there I
think it's a complicated circumstance
but I want people to know that this is a
woman that has thought about this stuff
I remember we had a discussion about
Justice Thomas and I was like you know
that's progress and she's like it's not
enough we need to make or so she's
trying to legitimately find a way to
make the world a better place and make
all of us and so this is not and I know
her and I've had these discussions and
she never we had the discussions they'd
be heated there was never turned into a
nasty thing she respected
my opinion but it was a so I hear these
things that I know and I'm thinking
ourselves they don't know her she's
really trying to find the truth and I
think if people can have these
discussions respectfully it'll be a
better place for everybody but so
anyways that's Wednesday thanks Scott
and Scott does make a good point I've
thought about this probably ever since I
was in high school thought about it
written about it because I've had
personal experiences I grew up in a home
where my parents grew up during
segregation and had to sit in the back
of the bus had to go to separate beaches
couldn't go and eat in the same places
as white people and growing up in
Richmond Virginia my father was one of
the first people to be admitted to the
Medical College of Virginia dental
school and he had professors he helped
fellow white students with their
homework they would get a higher grade
than my father so I know what racism is
I don't take it lightly I just I think
we're done of us are gonna ant
understand each other if we don't give
each other permission to disagree like
Scott said and everybody should be
welcomed at the table of discussion
let's head out to Los Angeles California
Don line for Democrats good morning yes
good morning I would like to say I agree
with some of the things that the lady
saying but I don't agree with everything
she's saying I definitely agree that
immigration illegal immigration is is
deadly to to black people Los Angeles
under a black mayor named Tom Bradley
was the first city in America to declare
themselves a sanctuary city and you
should see Los Angeles today but I have
to say that when black people vote
Democratic it's because certain things
that were done politically before you
and I came along that made them
gravitate to the Democratic Party why
did they go to the Democratic Party my
grandfather was a Republican okay but
once the Civil Rights Act of 1964 was
passed a lot of the Dixiecrats
went to the Republican Party that's why
you find so many right-wingers in the
Republican Party today now to be honest
with you I think politically speaking
that black people are between a rock and
hard place when it comes between the
Republicans and Democrats we don't
really have
a chance when you're voting at least I
feel I'm voting for the lesser of two
evils you know as the old people used to
say one of them is bad and the other one
is worse so that's usually what we're
voting for there's no such thing as the
perfect candidate okay I I'm leaning
more towards Bernie Sanders just going
around because I don't like some of the
things that Donald Trump has said he's
colorful I like he's entertaining to
look at but I wouldn't I wouldn't ever
vote for the guy because things he said
he's arrogant he's somewhat of an
egomaniac but I guess you have to be to
be as successful and his rich as he is
the other thing is no one has said
anything about Hillary Clinton when she
told I'll not lie about going to Kosovo
and being exposed to enemy fire and when
it was exposed in the media that she had
told and I'm not field and nobody talks
about that I'm just like kid gloves you
know and Hillary Clinton also shows a
lack of personal responsibility for an
elected official as State Department
Secretary using a private server and a
private email to evade scrutiny public
scrutiny so there's a lot on Hillary
Clinton that I think hopefully our
Republican nominee will tackle but done
you you bring up an important point and
I've been critical the Republican Party
for not going out and trying to earn the
black vote that's what the Republican
Party needs to do the Republican party
needs to make its case to black America
at the same time black America can't sit
back and expect that all the vigor that
that a political party is going to do
all the work for them black Americans
have to start doing their own scrutiny
and work and I think it's sad that you
just told me you're gonna work for
you're gonna vote for a party that you
feel is less bad you know that's not as
worse than the other party and I think
that that's where we fail I think that's
a two-way street it's like the chicken
and the egg right black Americans need
to hold both parties accountable and
there's no way to do that if they keep
voting single-handedly for Democrats
that we have to start diversifying our
vote and at the same time I don't know
what kind of trip my Republican Party is
on but the path forward is not the white
vote to the white house for the
Republican Party Mitt Romney
and McCain there's not much white vote
left in the electric America is getting
browner and that's where they're gonna
be forced to start asking for different
votes crystal Wright is editor and
publisher of conservative black chick
comm she's the author of con job how
Democrats gave us crime sanctuary cities
abortion profiteering and racial
division appreciate your time this
morning on the Washington journal yep
when I tuned into it on the weekends
usually its authors sharing up their new
releases watching the nonfiction authors
on book TV is the best television for
serious readers on c-span they can have
a longer conversation and delve into
their subject book TV weekends they
bring you author after author after
author that spotlight the work of
fascinating people
I love book TV and I'm a c-span fans
peter ferrara as a newest book is called
power to the people
mr. Ferrara is it possible to reform the
entitlement programs politically yes
only the way described in this book it
is possible and these reforms are all
positive popular pro-growth the book
describes how to reform every major
entitlement programs Social Security
Medicare welfare Obamacare Medicare
Medicaid all this explains how to reform
them all this is based on 30 years of
experience starting in the Reagan White
House I just got a school that heritage
Cato I contributed heavily to what
became the Ryan roadmap and this is the
extension of all these ideas into
element fruition some of these reforms
after you reform Social Security seniors
get higher benefits not lower benefits
the poor people get higher incomes on
lower incomes and sick people are able
to get better health care not less
health care and that's because these
reforms are not based on cutting
benefits you can't get anywhere cutting
benefits for poor people senior citizens
who are retired and sick people these
reforms are all based on struck
fundamental structural reforms changing
the way these programs operate so that
they contribute to the economy they're
pro-growth and they make the the bending
sand the beneficiaries of these programs
able to become self-sufficient self self
financing so a lot of this government
spending and these tax and
redistribution programs are shifted off
the federal budget altogether into the
private capital markets into the private
labor markets so instead of working
people today we spend a trillion dollars
a year in taxes taxpayers are taxed a
trillion dollars a year basically to pay
the bottom 20% of the income ladder not
to work and that's very unproductive
very counterproductive
hence simply have the declining labor
force participation rate you read about
under Obama this that actually started
before Obama is accelerated under Obama
because all these programs have been
expanded so when you pay people not to
work your detracting from the economy
not contributing the economy and one of
the reforms involves empowering workers
to choose personal savings investment
and insurance accounts to finance their
future Social Security benefits rather
than taxes and redistribution which is
all that Social Security is you get far
higher far far higher benefits from a
lifetime of savings and investment than
from a lifetime of no savings investment
which is all that Social Security is
there's no savings investment anywhere
in Social Security and so people
participating in a program lose the
benefit of that accumulating
accumulating returns when they ask
Albert Einstein the inventor of the
atomic bomb what's the most powerful
force in the universe
he said compound interest and that's
what you have working for you if you can
do a lifetime savings and investment
these it this was more powerful than the
atomic this is more powerful in your
life than the atomic bomb and so this is
why you'll have it they'll have middle
class couples able to retire as
millionaires if they are able to take
what they and their employers otherwise
pay into Social Security into a lifetime
of savings and investment and get that
accumulating compound interest over
their entire careers and even into their
retirement because all that money
continues to work for you even after
you've retired and so now you have
something working on your side and
that's why these reforms can be popular
and populist even and they would all be
pro-growth because all that seems in
capital contributes the economy all
those people not working today who go to
work would be the true to the economy
and so this is a prescription not just
for entire reform but for a renewed
economic prosperity economic prosperity
for the entire country what about the
risk factor when you're a little bit
older sometimes people aren't as willing
to be risky with their money well you
know this doesn't require you to be
risky with your money you know you can
make your own choices with this money
but you are still backed up by safety
net because when I sat down with Paul
Ryan we wrote the legislation for that
part of these reforms 2004 and 2005 that
became the foundation of the Ryan Road
and that bill provided that you only
backed up by a federal guarantee that
you would not get less than promised by
Social Security so you can gain but you
can't lose by making this choice on that
basis the chief after your Social
Security said these personal counts are
so obviously a good deal that he would
assume got a hundred percent of workers
would choose the personal counts because
they are so obviously a better deal than
Social Security this is the chief a
traditional security this is a lifetime
career the career numbers guy for Social
Security yeah that's what he wrote in
his score on the Ryan bill it's still
posted at the Social Security
Administration website that can still be
found but we're hoping to generate new
legislation that will provide for that
that will rally working people across
the country says yes give us power over
our own money and that's what this does
that's why it's called power to the
people gives you power over your own
money it gives you the choice and the
control over your own money just like
the reforms over repealing and placing
Obamacare that are discuss in the book
gives you power and control of your own
health care
just like the reforms about reforming
welfare in the book gives you inability
to become self-sufficient so you do
produce your own support and so again
its power to the people
peter ferrara does your approach in your
view reduce America's debt yes this is a
path for to actually paying off the
national debt because that's the other
part of this you see after all those
advantages of the reform this is the
part this is the kicker that's left out
after generation federal spending as %
of GDP is less than half of what it
would be otherwise if you are people are
favor of smaller government and they
want to reduce federal spending this
book explains how to do it it's the only
way just like it's the only way to
reform entitlements this is the only way
to make government smaller it's
described in this book it's actually not
a very long book but once you get the
idea you see how it applies to every
applies everywhere these are all ideas
that have proven to a weapon proved it
to work in the real world all have been
tried in America or elsewhere around the
world and have been proven to work
spectacularly and so let's take what's
proven to work and let's do more of it
what is the Heartland Institute dark
Lance Judas
a free market libertarian think-tank
that promotes exactly what the theme of
this book is power the people economic
prosperity and growth for everybody so
if this focus is on the most vulnerable
society we want the economic growth and
prosperity to spread to prune the poor
to seniors who are living on retirement
to sick people we want all this
prosperity this is a little map for
spreading that prosperity to every all
the most vulnerable of society that's
why the subtitle is the new road to
freedom and prosperity for the poor
seniors and those most in need of the
world's best health care because that's
exactly what it is the new road to
freedom and prosperity is Obamacare
so-called Obamacare isn't that a
free-market approach to health care no
it's the government approach government
is controlling everything in Obamacare
it takes away power from the people and
it gives power to the bureaucrats so the
government tells you what insurance you
must buy bureaucrats in Washington tell
you what must be covered in your
insurance the government tells insurance
companies what they must sell to you it
tells your employer what insurance they
have to buy for you this is all
government making decisions they're even
starting to tell your doctors and
hospitals what health care they can give
you and that's going to be more even
more of that in the future
so this is the Obamacare is not a
free-market system that's that's
misleading rhetoric for people who are
eat gullible and easily misled the
victims of calculated deception I have
called it but it's his Obama's approach
is the opposite of power of the people
it's a power to him in his buddies in
Washington because they think they're
smarter than everybody they're more
moral than everybody and so they've kind
of rediscovered the old rationale
centuries ago for the aristocracy we're
the smartest people were the moral
people we know what needs to be done you
guys just shut up and do what we tell
you and that's the message we get from
the Obama administration this is the
opposite of that the George W Bush
administration attempted a social
security reform but it got shot down
pretty quickly politically it didn't get
shot down he backed off he never he
never proposed his plan he talked about
during the
election he won with that he even
carried Florida which never would have
been present as you know if he hadn't
carried Florida he even carried Florida
and so when they ran for president they
used the formula exactly as I described
it and it worked spectacularly
and then once they got elected they
picked people inside of Washington try
to implement it and the people inside
Washington said are you nuts you know we
can't we can't do this we can't shift
power to the people we're gonna have to
give them all this power if we do that
we we can't do that we have to have
power in Washington and so that's the
real battle going on down today is where
do you stand with power in the people or
power to the bureaucrats power the
central government this is the this is
the real class struggle that's going on
entitlement program reform is the topic
of power to the people the new road to
freedom and prosperity for the poor
seniors and those most in need of the
world's best health care peter ferrara
is the author this is book TV on c-span
2 my name is Sarah believe I'm the
instructor here at Cramer books and it's
really my pleasure to welcome you and
welcome Randi tonight for his book blood
brothers Randy's a distinguished
professor of history at Purdue
University
he's written biographies and iconic
athletes and celebrities who specialized
in US history u.s. sports history and
the history of popular culture which
clearly combined in this new book the
blood brothers the failed friendship
between Muhammad Ali and Malcolm X is
really the first book to offer an
in-depth portrait of their complex
friendship and it really goes deep and
uses previously untapped resources from
FBI records to personal documents and so
we're so so pleased
here today and we're really glad that
Randy is joined at tonight by Kojo
Nnamdi co-host the show a live talk show
produced by wamu 88 5 then airs on
weekends at noon weekdays in your excuse
me on Fridays at noon Kojo hosts the
politics hour on WN you working as a
journalist in the district since the 70s
at multiple media multiple media outlets
koujun has been dubbed quote The
Washingtonian of the Year by
Washingtonian magazine and it has been
listed among the district's most
influential people by the Pope by that
publication Washingtonian and I'd
easiest we're so glad that Co Joe could
join us tonight this is one of our
vinnie partner amends with w mu 88 5 our
local NPR station we are so pleased to
partner eliminating you they share so
many of our values that bring community
together having great discussions and
having great conversations and asking
wonderful questions so we're so glad
that w mu can be here in our community
and here tonight in the bookstore thank
you again so much for coming everybody
please join me in welcoming Randy
Roberts and Kojo Nnamdi thank you so
very much Sarah and thank you all for
showing up on what's clearly a dark and
stormy night if you've been to Bermuda
you know that's a drink also you can get
a dark and stormy tonight would be a
good night for a dark and stormy before
we get started with tonight's events I
just like not only to thank Sarah and
the whole staff here at Cramer books but
the WLAN you team is working with the
team here on events because well we know
that listeners are also readers and
tonight we're here as you heard to talk
with Randy Roberts about Blood Brothers
he and I will get the conversation
rolling and move to a question and
answer session with you after we have
talked for a little while but first
Randy Roberts welcome thank you very
much happy to be here and I am happy to
be here with you
first what got you started on looking at
this you have written about sports stars
and sports legends before
but this as far as I can see is the
first time you looked at this
combustible mix of sports and politics
in a relationship well I have looked at
relationships before I hate what I did I
did it a book earlier on Joe Namath